this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people actually build wealth
actually do work that they love
and actually create amazing
relationships rachel cruz number one
best-selling author and ramsey
personality and my daughter is with me
today as a co-host we'll be taking your
questions about your life and your money
the phone number is free some say the
advice is worth what you pay for it
triple eight eight two five five two two
that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five looks like mario's gonna
start us off this hour and he is in
atlanta hey mario how are you
i'm doing better than i deserve as usa
dave i'm doing great glad to be on the
show we're honored to have you sir how
can we help him
um so the big the big point is i'm
fairly new i'm not new to you but really
new to the show and i'm really on fire
and on board about just becoming
financially free
debt-free
the teachings that you and your team
teach are phenomenal and my big question
is i want to know the best way
to get my wife on board with
implementing some of the
drastic changes that we would need to
make in order to get to that point um i
make a pretty good
um i have a strong income
um
the the i know all of our debt areas i
know the areas that you know where i
feel like we're you know spending too
much or over indulging but i know that
i'm going to get some resistance with
the changes that we're going to need to
make in order to get to where i know
that we can get to give me an example of
one of the changes that you think you
need to make that you think you're going
to get resistance on
there's some areas of convenience like
going out to eat a lot
um or or ordering food how much data a
lot of
um including house no no
okay
uh credit card debt i'm at about fifteen
thousand dollars credit card debt uh
student loans total
um around seventy five thousand
um and i have one car that's not
i have one car that's not completely
paid off and i think we owe 12 000 on
that car
and what's your household income
uh 175. okay that's a great income so
mario what's your what what's causing
you to believe that she's going to have
a hard time
with all of this is it comments she's
made is it something that in your head
you just
know her and you're you know you know
what's going to be coming has she given
you clues on it like oh
yeah absolutely a comment she's made
there's other things that i've
so why
so then for her in these conversations
what's the
what are her hesitations
um a lot of it has to do with our kids
okay okay um so like for instance um
i'll say okay hey we've completely paid
off this particular credit card we're
not going to use it we're going to put
it up interest rate is high on this
thing it doesn't make sense and paying
somebody to borrow from my future self
you know i do all of that and she's like
great sounds good
uh but then time will go on
and how she charges on the credit card
and then when i say hey what happened
here why did this take place and it was
like oh i had to do this i had to make
this decision and do this and you know
yeah and so it's just kind of like
you know these things
a lot of times it's with the girls yes
you know my kids sure and and it's life
right because you guys have not put
systems in place for life to look
different so you're still keeping the
credit card we're gonna put this credit
card over here we shouldn't touch it but
it's still there get rid of it get rid
of it you guys do you guys have a
written budget that you have together
sharing an account saying hey here's
here's the line item for the kids this
is what we're going to spend on the kids
here's the line item for you me food out
to eat clothes here's where every single
dollar this month is going
i've done all of that no have you guys
together no mario have you guys together
done that we have we done that or have
you done that
so
i i have done it and i've shared it and
it's communicated this looks good i'm on
board let's do it let's run this plan
and we'll start running the plan and
okay
totally so mario i also think
i'm sure ramsay has become a cuss word
in your house because a little bit of me
i'm fearful that you're using this
against her because i don't believe your
wife is malicious i think she's a great
mom probably a great wife and so so
these things life is just happening to
her and she's reacting obviously not in
the way that you would prefer or that
even what we would teach right she's
going charging the credit card
but it's not malicious and so um so i
think that there needs to be a higher
level conversation to say okay
you and i together as a couple where do
we want to be what do we want life to
look like in five years
what do we want um our what what is our
why like does does she have any level of
pain or stress around money is she
worried in any way like i want you guys
to
yeah
i
me me for the most part i am you're the
way to go i'm gonna have to work until i
retired
you're treating her like she's your
teenage daughter
she's not a partner and she's not a
partner in any of this
you're just bringing the budget and
laying it down giving some instructions
about a credit card and then you're
shocked that she didn't do what you told
her to do
uh she's not a partner rachel's right
you need to get above this and the two
of you need to sit down with the kids
away or the kids in bed and say we have
and two thousand dollars in debt we make
175 000
that makes us stupid people we need to
change some stuff here we're broke and
we make 175 000 a year we have got to as
a couple aim at something bigger than
kids clothes
lord jesus
really yeah okay and so we've got to
have a big plan that we're going at now
honey he feel it i know i know i know
but this is him and his wife talking
okay yes we have to get on the same page
i do not want to be your daddy
i don't want to be your daddy
i i i i want to be your husband i need i
need like a grown woman beside me
helping me make decisions about our
future she needs an input in all of them
and then she gets input that she gets to
say and then by god when she gives input
it's a contract yes
but she has no reason she has no
contract with you now because you
dictated it to her and walked away and
then were shocked that she went and
bought kids clothes on a credit card
because she had no buy-in she had no
buy-in none whatsoever she didn't have a
voice in this and she has no belief in
the overall vision she was just going
along with you yes and i would say this
too just as an encouragement mario that
the conversations that i feel like
winston and i the best conversations we
have around money is not really even
about money it's more like hey let's
just dream and in five years
what do we want our life to look like
how how old are the girls going to be uh
what kind of car do we want to drive
what vacations do we take what do we
want to be giving to in general like
allow your numbers then to motivate you
to your goals together as a couple where
you guys both want to go and then the
day-to-day plays into that but kind of
there's a i mean i'm looking at her i'm
going i'll make 175 000 a year
i'm really not okay with us being broke
which is crazy but also there's a level
yes i know but there's also a level
marriage-wise to get above it to have a
conversation i think it's all of that
yeah i just gave a bit of that but i
think you got to say look we're sloppy
yeah we're disorganized yes we're fact
what can we do to help you
what can we do together to fix this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author joins me this
hour rachel and george and i have spent
the morning going over our talk and uh
stuff we're doing tomorrow night the
real estate
reality check it is a free live stream
that you can watch it'll be about an
hour long you can join us july the 14th
it's 7 p.m central time free live stream
just go to ramseysolutions.com we're
going to dig into
the real estate market all the facts
no
feelings just facts we're gonna address
your feelings but we don't make
decisions based on those things right
it's a crazy it's still a crazy world
out there there's still a lot of
fear and questions and
predictions and
anger anger there's a lot of anger and
are you predicting that's not gonna
first not just i can't buy a house so
i'm mad at dave
you know that kind of anger oh you know
there's a lot of that
so um yeah i mean i posted a blog about
this stuff uh last week and it's gotten
like i don't know several hundred
thousand or almost a million views or
whatever but the comments are angry
it's because of the formula yeah well
they just don't no period they just
don't you know i'll never i'll never
listen to you again
because i'm basically you know just
saying the housing market's not going to
crash yeah and that pisses people off
you know they want it to crash
it's weird so yeah there's just when
there's that much fear people
misinterpret it all kinds of ways and
it's very interesting so we're going to
cover the facts we're actually going to
have a little bit of a college class
almost professor dave he's coming out
getting my little profile
and um that's about as close as i'll
ever get to that but um
and uh we're going to cover some of that
and then george and rachel and i will go
through some of your feelings and
comments and your um you know things
your people are concerned about
we want to address what people are
concerned and frustrated yeah and
frustrated because what you could buy 36
months ago in a house
is not the thing you can buy now and
that's frustrating when you've saved up
and you've got yourself out of debt and
all of it so what does it look like and
what's the reality of of grieving what
was expectations finger when i filled up
my raptor
you know okay filling up your truck and
buying a home though i know but it's
still it's still frustration it's like i
can't control the price of this crap i
just have to put it in my truck you know
and then i'm laying in the i told him
yesterday i was laying on the pavement
holding my heart having a heart attack
and rachel drove up in her tesla and
laughed at me because she didn't have to
buy gas so
[Laughter]
plug her in
plug her in
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
when you get ready to put up a shade or
some kind of window covering you get
free samples free shipping new promos
all the time this is a great company
we've been endorsing them for a long
time and they take great care of you use
the promo code at blinds.com promo code
ramsey
today's question comes from lindsay in
albuquerque
we have ten thousand dollars beyond our
six-month emergency savings and we wanna
help we want to use that to help pay
down our mortgage because we have no
other debt but with inflation we partly
feel the need to keep it in case
inflation gets worse
should we save it or put it towards the
mortgage thanks so much you have
inspired us to live like no one else um
it's a great question i mean inflation
just came out to what 9.1
in june it went up higher than they were
even expecting and predicting um so it
is something obviously that's affecting
all of us we were laughing about the gas
earlier but groceries i mean all of it
the everyday necessities it's just gone
up and everyone's feeling it
and so i don't think it's enough
to not continue on the baby steps
because lindsay if you guys have an
emergency fund in place it may just mean
adjusting your monthly budget which is
not always fun and exciting but
where you are today i would do that and
continue to pay off the mortgage because
becoming debt-free and not having a
mortgage payment is going to free up
more monthly
to put towards that inflation uh and
towards your budget you know to all your
monthly expenses so i would
continue to put that ten thousand
dollars towards your mortgage because
you have an emergency fund very good the
here's the thing
the ten thousand dollars anytime you
have a
an ongoing chronic event
it's not a singular event it's going to
keep going
and you want to offset that
with a lump sum
that is always a recipe for mathematical
suicide because you're going to burn the
lump sum and then you're screwed because
you never made any changes to adjust to
the situation
okay so example of that is we saved up
twenty thousand dollars my wife wanted
to quit and come home
and uh that twenty thousand dollars is
going to make it okay to not have her
income
no it's not
because if you're burning through the 20
000 because your spending was at a level
higher than his income while she comes
home and when you burn through the 20
000 you're screwed yep yep so that's a
chronic ongoing
serial event which is her income goes
away permanently
monthly we are under water because we
made no changes and the lump sum made it
feel better until the lump sum is gone
right and that's the exact same thing
here okay let's talk about inflation for
a second can we because it continues to
rise
and what are you seeing when you're
looking out it's like okay because what
causes inflation you know we say around
here supply and demand and we can talk
about that more but but there's a lot of
a lot of people
pointing fingers a lot of different
directions you know biden saying well
the war in iraq and then
the war in ukraine and russia is causing
it uh people are saying well the fed
runs in the i mean there's there's
fingers pointing everywhere of what's
causing inflation and it continues to
rise it's not like we're seeing it
yeah i don't know
like my personal opinion is that's a
lagging indicator the the cpi that that
most that it's not i mean this time next
year we're not going to be at nine
percent i just don't i really don't
believe it i predicted that we were
going to be here now a year ago you did
which is and but and i don't think we'll
be here now a year from now it'll be
better yeah gonna be a lot better and
here's why there's three major
components to this inflation it is not a
white hot economy that caused the
inflation in the 70s we had a white hot
overheated economy and it drove things
crazy
coved and by and large the pandemic the
economic suppression when we shut down
the world
we left entire gaps
in supply factories weren't making cars
factories weren't making lumber
factories weren't
services weren't being provided so we
left these huge gaps
and so we ended up with shortages in
everything
okay and we have supply chain problems
we get because we couldn't get stuff off
the ocean it was sitting in the bay at
la and that kind of stuff so all of
those shortages anytime there's a
shortage of something it runs the price
up now that's smoothing out okay for
instance lumber went up triple
it was running about 500 a board foot
and then it went to 1700 aboard foot it
went up triple and now it's back to
about 480 of board foot right now okay
so it's the factories caught up
to this the supply caught up through the
demand and the price came back and
normalized same is happening with cars
used cars for the first time in the
history of mankind went up
you know they went up and the reason
they went up was there was no new cars
right and once new cars started hitting
the lots again the factory started
emptying the car car the car containers
right there on the block boom boom boom
they start lining up on the lot now you
got new cars so that again that's
absorbing some of the demand there's
more supply so you could use cars are
coming back down
and they're going to start going down
again like they used to yeah okay so
we're seeing that part of the inflation
go away but it's not all gone yet and
it's still a component it's going up
it's still component of that night okay
the the cpi is the consumer price index
okay that is the measure of inflation
and that's the measure of goods and
services and they've got it weighted
meaning that the things that you spend
the most on have the bigger portion of
creating that nine percent
okay so uh the things that you spend the
least on actual dollars okay so for
example housing
is an element of the cpi well obviously
in all of our budgets most people's
budgets that have a house payment
housing is the biggest line item in your
budget so it's the biggest portion so as
long as housing is going up
your cpi is going to go up
so housing goes up a little
bread and uh milk and milk eggs and
cheese and crackers and all that stuff
everything but look at the number of
dollars you spend on that versus the
number dollars you spend on housing
right if that goes way down and housing
goes up you're still going to see
inflation okay okay
but if housing goes down
and
uh housing values housing values the
prices go down the values go down and
milk and bread doubles you might not
even see inflation because the house
price going down might might so the
housing market has caused all this
inflation drives a lot of it is what i'm
saying okay and energy's the other one
energy the the cost of the pump that's
what's killing us and that one is a
political issue
that's not an economic issue that was
created by biden shutting it off to go
green
and we did that created tremendous
shortage and it's doubled our gas prices
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage stephanie is with
us hi stephanie how are you hi i'm good
dave and rachel how are you both we're
honored to have you where do you live i
am uh
about 25 minutes away from boston
massachusetts awesome how much debt have
you paid off about hundred and five
thousand wait way to go kiddo excellent
how long did this take you uh three
years and eight months wow and your
range of income during that time so i
started at about 60 000 um and i ended
at 115 000. excellent
and uh what do you do for a living um so
i work for a hospital i'm a manager in
it good for you okay cool and what kind
of debt was the hundred and five
thousand so it was everything dave uh
about three hundred and sixty thousand
sixty dollars was medical um i had
thirty one hundred in a car loan uh six
sixty two hundred personal loan seven
thousand in credit card debt and the
biggest was my student loans it was
about eighty eight thousand wow
okay very cool okay tell us your story
what happened three years and eight
months ago that put you on this journey
so i've i've been living with that since
i was 18. so i from the first time i got
a credit card i just how old are you now
36. okay so it took me 18 years to get
here okay um but so 2018 um like i said
i'd been struggling for many years um
and you know i'd really have been
praying and asking god to really help me
um because i never knew how to budget
just was out of control didn't know what
to do
so september 2018 i was home on
maternity leave i had my third child um
and i was actually searching for sermons
really to watch on youtube
and then in my feed it came this couple
video came up and the title was uh dave
ramsey ruined our lives and so i never
saw the couple before and never watched
them ever and i never heard your name um
so but it was a pretty you know
good-looking couple sharp couple so i
decided to watch
and they proceeded to say how you know
they
from the time they started your program
they were
getting out of debt i mean you know
selling things left and right living on
rice and beans not going out just you
know making sacrifices to live the life
that they wanted to live ultimately
and so i you know sat and i believe it
was divine connection i believe god led
me to that video um and so as i was
watching i said wow like they can do it
i can do it too um so i started
searching for you on youtube um
at that time i just saw a lot of the
short videos the seven to ten minute
clips i didn't know you had a show um
but i just started digging into those
learned about these you know the seven
baby steps i learned about you know just
what you teach what you practice and it
all made sense um like i said i was on
maternity leave so i only had i was
making half of my income at the time um
because i was it was just using my
vacation time to try and spread the time
out
so i downloaded the ever dollar app and
i couldn't really start the budget until
october that's when i went back to work
but i had the budget in place i listened
to you know rachel cruz and all the
material that you guys put out there and
tried to do my budget as best i could
and so once i went back to work in
october my budget was set and i you know
i pretty much hit the ground running
i initially started out i was you know
picking up instacart shifts um you know
even with sometimes my little kids in
the car and my daughter
i
i would work full-time during the day
and i picked up a temp agency job you
know and at the evening so we were home
um it was during covert so you know kids
running around in the background but i'm
doing a temp agency job and i also you
know delivered pizza for dominoes um you
know a short while
fast forward to
2020 december 2020 i um interviewed and
got got a position at another hospital
so that jumped me up in my pay
about 20 000
and the next year 2021 about november i
got a promotion to manager so and that
jumped me up as well so that has been my
journey up you know through 2018 to wow
you worked your tail off kiddo i was and
you know what i believed in the vision i
believed what you taught and i from that
first paying off that first credit card
just seeing
how free you know how a little bit of
you know space in my budget and i said
wow this really works and i was
determined regardless of what people
said i was determined that i was going
to do it not just for myself and my my
kids to leave a legacy and that's really
why i kept going
wow congratulations
very proud of you that's a big deal i
mean you know we get all different types
of debt-free screams on the stage and we
celebrate them all but you doing this
with little ones
over three years working all these
shifts i mean you've done the hard work
you've done it congratulations thank you
incredible absolutely incredible
beautiful what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is it
sounds like seven extra jobs yeah
well in perseverance but i think the
biggest thing is a mindset mindset
change um you know people that i talk to
and i let them i share my journey with
they're happy for me but
you know a lot of what i hear is you
know you'll never be out of debt you're
always going to have debt and i by
soaking myself into your show you know
listening watching all the debt free
screams that have come across the stage
you know watching the everyday
millionaire you know part like listening
to all these people that have done it
and they live debt free it is possible
so i think it requires a mindset shift
you know being around different people
listening but realizing that it is
possible but also perseverance i mean
regardless of what comes i mean i had
life happen during those three and you
know eight months so
but it's perseverance being willing to
persevere through and trusting god in
the process yeah because once you've
committed to it he will see you through
the end amen amen well done very very
very well done who are your biggest um i
would say a little bit of everybody i
mean my mom is here my family they all
supported me through this journey
my co-workers at work and when i at the
time when i could pick up on call shifts
they would they wouldn't know i was on
this journey and so they would you know
help me out you know send me their
on-call shifts but i think the biggest
one is my oldest daughter um
during cove she was my babysitter when i
had to pick up the shifts she was my
babysitter and she sacrificed a lot but
she knew what we were after she knew the
reason why we sacrificed and she was
willing to delay gratification for a
season so that we could be here today
you know and become debt free so i would
say she's my biggest out of out of
everyone my biggest supporter my biggest
cheerleader
was it worth it absolutely
absolutely how's it feel to be free
amazing i cashflowed this trip here it
wasn't cheap
and i but i i didn't stress the money's
there
it's absolutely amazing and i wouldn't i
wouldn't trade anything for the world i
would do it again if i had to
and you don't have any payments that's
the beauty of
making a hundred and fifteen hundred
twenty thousand dollars a year and the
ability to pick up and do whatever you
need to do because you've proven that to
yourself absolutely into your kids so
your kids got to witness a warrior
princess
that's beautiful amen yeah you got after
it kiddo you really got after it well
done amen very very congratulations
you're a good mom absolutely good mom we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that is definitely the next
chapter in your story you are on your
way
and a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away to someone who is
inspired by your story that you run into
because i'm sure you've talked about it
soon
and uh of course financial peace
university we want you to go through the
class we just launched the new videos
the best best class we've ever had at
financial peace right now available it's
a one-year membership we'll give you
that as well if you've been through it
you want to give it away that's fine
we're happy to have you
uh pass it on however you want to do it
it's very very good all right bring the
kiddos up and tell us their names and
ages
so i have sanaya sanaya is 15 years old
emmanuella she is five and my youngest
one uh atara she's three years old all
right
love it beautiful very very very well
done all right stephanie from boston
mass three years and eight months to pay
off a hundred and five thousand 63 jobs
i'm exaggerating a tiny bit but not much
and some help from the teenage daughter
that's just beautiful 60 to 115 000
income during that time count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three
two one we're done
[Applause]
well done
oh man man
she made me tear up
she gets it
she gets it and she pushed it through
that's beautiful very very well done
that lady uh ladies and gentlemen force
of nature right there man that's what
you have to do
she said it beautifully what's it take
it takes a mindset i know i know and you
have the and you know it's not forever
it's a mindset change but in those
moments in those nights it's hard to
leave and she still did i'm gonna live
like no one else so that later i can
live and give like no one else this is
the ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today open phones at
825-5225 ben's with us in salt lake hey
ben what's up
hey dave hey rachel thank you for taking
my call
um i've gotten an investment property
and i'm debating whether or not to sell
it i've got enough equity in it to pay
off my mortgage plus
you know quite a bit extra and i'm just
wondering if it makes sense to go ahead
and sell it
okay what do you uh what's it worth
um best estimate is about 300k okay
what's your home worth
uh a b
750-800k
okay
all right
and how much you have left on your house
ben to pay off about 120
okay what's your household income
about 190. okay
all right well you can run the numbers
out both ways okay because here's the
goal
the goal is to end up with
zero debt because that is your fastest
method to build wealth
okay
at least the most at least the fastest
right way to build wealth because it's
gonna it's gonna free up everything and
you're gonna have the right direction so
if you had no payments making 190 but
you didn't have a
a rental property anymore
you would probably begin to save towards
buying your next paid for investment
property wouldn't you
yes in 10 years from today you would
have paid for house paid for rental
property 10 years from today if you just
beat on both of these with 190 000
income you probably can work your way
through and be debt-free
on both of them by 10 years from today
right
yeah yeah when i run out the numbers
it's more like
four or five yeah okay so really the
trade-off is
four or five years the trade-off is not
i'm going to be in debt the rest of my
life because i don't make this decision
yeah yeah and the other side of that is
also the taxes that would be due if we
did sell it well that's one side of it
the other side of it is the peace and
freedom you would have without screwing
with a renter or a mortgage
and um very true you know so there's
trade-offs all the way around this deal
uh so i i think i love investment real
estate if you listen to this for very
long you know that i own a bunch of it
personally but not everyone should own
real estate not everybody likes it
um and not everybody wants to mess with
it so this particular 300 000 investment
property um
you like it love it
don't care
um
like it
okay so 10 years from now you'll be glad
you own it
yeah yes definitely okay i'm probably
just gonna work through paying them both
off
okay okay that's excellent advice you
see how i got there
yeah yeah absolutely that's how i got
there is probably more important than
the actual advice
but um you know again if it was going to
take you 20 years
i you know if you told me you had an 80
000 income
uh i'd say your investment problem by 30
seconds
right right no that's that's not the
case yeah but i mean you see what you
see how i'm how i'm analyzing that
that's my point
yeah yes i do okay cool okay so what's
your threshold then i thought you were
going to say something different oh
really yeah i thought you would say
sell it pay off the house take that five
years five years about my threshold okay
that's that was my question if he can
clear the deck in five years in five
years so same thing on paying off your
car because okay think about your car
okay what do we tell people we tell
people yeah if you can get it off
18 to 24 months right yeah then it's
okay but it's gonna take you four years
so why wouldn't you just sell the car
every time
because you're gonna turn around buy
another one
yeah but a cheaper one i know but i'm
saying if you pay if you could pay off
the car in 18 months and you sell it
today to get off debt get out of debt
you're going to be turned around buying
another car
in 18 months
so it's you know you it just was a
dollar swap
in other words the car was not
weighing you down to the point you
couldn't get out of that right
right and the same thing's true here the
five-year mark yes because he can clear
his mortgage
and his house yeah when most of the
people following the baby steps are
debt-free house and everything takes him
about seven to eight years to pay off
their home alone just the home right
right because he
high has an inordinately high income in
relation to his mortgages yes yep then
he can knock it out he could do both but
again if it was going to drag out 12
years i'd have flipped it sure sure and
the thing that would have caused that to
happen would been if his income is lower
yes okay but then on the other end
though
he sells it
gets he's 100 free yeah 100 free and
then he goes and buys
a cheaper rental later three or four or
five years from now so he's back in the
rental business and either way at the
end of five to seven still in the rental
business at the end of five or seven
years he has a paid for mortgage and a
rental business at the end of 18 months
you still got a nice car yep you just
had you didn't have to flip in and out
of it was all true that's the difference
and so if this was like who wants to be
a millionaire or some game show i would
have lost
well
i really was like expecting you
to say sell it and sell it and pay off
the mortgage have the piece have your
extra cash and if you want to go buy
something else later
and cash comp you know and of course
there's another element to this he likes
the rental property
fair if he said you know it's a bad
neighborhood i'm not that thrilled with
it i probably wouldn't buy it again
then sure
let's go ahead and flip it out now yep
you know but he's like he didn't love it
if his mortgage was different if his
mortgage was different his income was
different or if he liked the didn't like
the property
all right
you learn something new every day
[Laughter]
brad is in toledo hey brad what's up
hey how you guys doing great man how can
we help
um so my wife and i we're frequent
listeners um
we've been investing for a while we're
just kind of struggling to understand
some of the advice that you put out
there when it comes to like a rock
versus a brokerage account
so we currently we have no debt
we bring home about or we before tax
about 175 a year
our living expenses are like 45 000.
so that would put us in like a zero
percent or a zero percent capital gains
tax bracket for a long-term capital
gains you know at that kind of living
expense
so what's the advantage of a roth
contribution
versus like a brokerage account when you
fall into that zero percent long-term
capital gains tax bracket
well i'm sorry take me one more time for
my i got lost from 175 000 income
you said right
yes
and and it's it's uh why is it
why with that income you have a zero
percent capital gains again
well i'm just looking at in the future
our living expenses if we were to
replace that with investment income
rather than
try to replace our 175 if we were trying
to cover our living expenses but capital
gains doesn't go to zero just because
you want to cover your living expenses
when you have capital gains on a
brokerage account when you have capital
gains on a brokerage account and 175
thousand dollars you pay 15 on it zero
percent
correct
but choice
so if you're gonna pay 15 on it versus
zero percent and a roth
doesn't that answer your question
yes in that scenario yes but i'm saying
if our income is possible what possible
scenario what possible scenario with 175
000 do you get a zero percent capital
gains rate he's going to tell you
go brad
never never uh at 175 000 never what do
you make we were to pursue different
careers where we where we've made less
money and it was more
you know
of a passion job or something like that
i would suggest you don't do that i
suggest you find a passion job that pays
you 200
um not a passion job that pays you 14.
it's not going to work out so it's not
going to work out for you so
um you make you currently make 175 000 a
year if you are truly going
to go on the mission field and make zero
then you know we can have this
discussion but you're not
okay you're going to pay 15 on a
brokerage account and you you just want
to screw around with taxes and find out
some or screw around flipping stocks and
find out some way that that's okay to do
no it's not smart
i would buy mutual funds in a roth ira
okay so what if brad wakes up tomorrow
and says we're going to go work for a
non-profit we're my wife and i together
we're going to make 45 000 yeah then
they're gonna have the capital gains tax
at forty five thousand
you don't have zero capital gains unless
you make under twenty thousand bucks i
mean it's you know you gotta be the
poverty level
and going from 175 to the poverty level
in order to have zero capital gains is
not a wise move
okay that's just that there's there's
nothing in this whole scenario that this
is like something no
no
i i i don't think it's going to happen
in your world sir and so you need to do
roth iras
it's pretty simple the math is going to
work out better for you all the way
around thanks for the call
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave
your story that's ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your
story live from the headquarters of
ramsey solutions it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host here on the air my
daughter as well the phone number is
triple eight eight two five
five two two five starting this hour off
is dana in california hi dana how are
you
hi thank you for taking my call i'm
doing well how are you better than i
deserve what's
up well um my husband passed away a
little over a year ago and i know that
you
yeah um i know that you advise people
not to make big decisions for about six
months but
i have a
nine-year-old daughter and he passed
away in the home so we sold the home
and i took
um
one of the distributions i took a
distribution from one of his accounts to
pay off our debt and put towards the
down payment on the home that we
purchased
we relocated
anyway now i have a tax burden of 33 000
because i
used
i didn't because i took the distribution
from that account and i'm just wondering
if there's some loophole or
something that my tax person is missing
perhaps you know because
it's go it went from one investment to
the home which is technically another
investment so
just wondering i was out of debt for a
hot second and now this
i'm sorry dana i'm sorry how old was he
um he was 36. my goodness
okay um what other monies do you have
i have
well i have my monthly income um what do
you make and
i'll make a little over 90 000 this year
okay good
so i'll be able to i mean
i will be able to pay it off i've
already run the numbers and i can pay it
off in about a year but it's putting me
i wanted to have
the home paid off and just yeah it's
just slowing things down and i what
other do you have any other money you
said you took a distribution from this
particular fund what was what's left in
it
um there is another fund but it's
i can't do anything with it right now
because it's because of the way that he
passed away there's there was no life
insurance um
but this other retirement account is
basically understand so i have it i mean
it'll be fine but
um it's just pending
like a workers comp situation
okay
all right and how much does it amount to
oh
that one is 168 000. okay when will that
situation be settled do you think
i'm hoping um by june of next year okay
when is the tax bill due next april
or is already due
it's to
it's due now it was due last april
it's late
yes it's late i i i filed an extension
but still extensions don't extensions
don't extend payment due
correct yes i'll extend the filing so
you it was due in april okay
and um the money the the retirement
account you took it out of was how much
how much is left in it
i it was a hundred and eight thousand so
i took the entire account and put it
towards my house i put okay so you don't
have any money left except the
retirement that's in dispute
yes i right i have i have about 20 000
in other retirement funds i have my
retirement fund that's
10 000 and then i have another do you
have any money in just savings
i haven't made my thousand dollars how
much emergency fund how much 1000. oh
okay all right
okay
um okay the answer to your question is
no there's nothing you can do you
um you got bad advice
and this what the moves that you made
have pinched you into a corner
um because your house is not an
investment that is transferable from a
from a retirement account
both are technically
you know qualify under the term
investment but for tax purposes they're
not even close to being the same thing
so no you you're going to pay 33 000 if
you made a bad move
um yeah so
what i would do is this is um
you owe you have a debt of 33 000
the debt is with the irs at a high
interest rate and high penalties
okay yes
so getting it turning it into a
different kind of debt
is not taking out debt it's just
changing the type of debt it is so if
you can go down to your credit union
making 90 000 bucks and borrow 33 000
and pay it off
that'd be the thing to do
okay i was wondering about that yes the
tax person said that if they're they're
good debtors you might as well just
leave it and change it your tax person
is apparently an absolute idiot
he got you into this in the first place
and now he's giving you that advice
irs irs interest rates are nowhere and
penalties are nowhere even close to the
credit union
they're a loan shark
actually i i didn't ask for anybody's
advice when i took the um
the distribution and put it towards the
home but okay all right then i won't
blame him for that but no that's that's
ridiculous advice so no you you can pay
the irs off in a year if you want but
you're going to pay a ridiculous
interest rate i'd rather you pay off
your credit union in nine months
okay yeah i'll i can go do that today i
was wondering about that okay that's
going to be your best move and then uh
and then i want you to slow down here
okay
okay
slow down
quit you know you you
um
there are some things you needed to do
because of the situation
i get that okay
but but you left yourself you cost
yourself 35 grand
because of it because you just you you
know and i'm not picking on you i just
don't want you to do this again next
time so slow down that's why we tell
people to move slow now again i i get
that you sold the house or you needed to
sell the house emotionally that's fine
but i wouldn't mind it if you moved into
a rental for a little while
until some of this stuff got cleared up
until you had the money saved up to do
some other things clear your debts i i
would have advised you to go slower
but um so that's okay hard situation
it's horrible it's horrible to go
through him so having a having a kid and
then this happening dana at your age and
situation when it is it's
your mind is isn't a fog so don't have
the the guilt and the shame no i'm not
trying to do that no no i know you're
not but just saying to her though
because i think so many money mistakes
whether you're in the situation or not
follow people and i think people beat
themselves up
like why did i do this why do i do this
because that number just continues to
follow you so i
as much as you can dana just let you let
it go you're a good mom 33 out but make
the commitment then and learn from
the bruises
and uh we always got to learn from our
bruises and that's um that's all i want
you to do i don't want you to carry it
as a permanent wound
that's not my goal here but i do want
you to learn from the bruce so yeah go
take out a credit union loan pay it off
don't take financial advice from your
tax person
um
they're apparently not very good at it
and um
then
let's get it paid off as quick as we can
and then slow down
just make 90 give yourself some room to
heal girl you've been through hell i'm
so sorry
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today parents if you've got
school-aged kids the last thing you want
is for them to be
normal adults broke
you want them to be weird not broke like
you and that's why you've already got
them listening to ramsay show in the
backseat of your car all that kind of
stuff we're 100 on board with that we
got tons of stuff to help you and your
kids teachers
packed into our back to school sale one
of the biggest challenges teachers face
is getting students to actually engage
in classroom conversations dr john
deloney created classroom editions of
his questions for human cards they're
made for elementary middle and high
school kids help them build lifelong
friendships and real conversations at
home you can keep the fun and the
learning going with our popular
children's books and tools the adventure
pack family favorite that includes a new
story time collection and if there's a
teacher in your life or your kid's life
pick them up a questions for humans
classroom additions
good icebreaker gets conversations going
among the kiddos and grab one of our
family favorite children's products help
out with all this we're all there to
help you at ramseysolutions.com
evan's with us in winston-salem hi evan
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um well me and my wife uh we're on baby
step 3b trying to stay for a house and
we've got a chance to buy a house
from a family member um she's my wife's
cousin
and uh not really like a close family
member but they're offering it to us at
um 3.5
interest on a 15-year fixed rate owner
financing
and i've called around to the bank the
best that i can do is probably around
four
or a little over four and so we
me and my wife were long-time listeners
and we just wasn't sure
about owner finance center if that was a
safe thing to do
owner financing is as safe as anything
else if you have a good attorney draft
they equip draft the
uh documents it's not a land contract
it's an actual mortgage and the deed of
the house goes into your name
yes okay there's no land contracts at
all we don't do those okay now the
downside of the whole scenario you're
giving the the other the other upside is
you're gonna have a lot less costs
involved closing costs
other things that you're gonna not have
with owner financing so that part's all
wonderful
how often do you have dinner with this
cousin
uh this is the first time that we've
spoken to them and
probably at their wedding about 10 years
ago maybe okay so you never see them
you're not mad at them but you just it's
not a relationship you have
no it's this this is not one that we
have correct because here's the thing
it's going to affect whatever
relationship you have
the borrower is slave to the lender
when you borrow money from someone you
change your relationship from cousin to
master
yep
okay and so if you're if your
father-in-law loans you this money i
would tell you no
because thanksgiving dinner tastes
different when you eat with your master
it will change the tone the relationship
of your between you and your wife your
her dad all that kind of stuff never do
that one
but this one is really there's not much
of a relationship here this is almost
like a stranger
yes and so i'm probably doing it
okay
i agree um
it's another one evan in in like just
the in
in most of the calls though when it
comes to borrowing money from family
it's just an absolute no uh but there's
these exceptions like this this is so
distant yeah where it's so distant and
it's like
there's not really you're not gonna be
with them you're not seeing them every
day you guys aren't chatting and talking
and there's not really much of a
relationship
to hinder because there's not much of a
relationship so
so in that makes nobody's mad we're not
saying that oh no but it's just you know
the thing is if it absolutely completely
went bad and went sideways and everybody
was mad it really wouldn't change your
life
right yeah and we're not calling that
we're not saying it's going to happen
but the the point being
that you know if you borrow from your
father-in-law that that you lose that
relationship or a sibling or an in-law i
mean yeah somebody
said spending time with yeah
but um like rachel's got cousins that
she actually has really tight
relationships with
right that you would not do this you
would not do this deal with them
not a chance i'm not changing because
i'm telling you man the old joke is if
you loan your brother-in-law 100 and he
never speaks to you again was it worth
it right i mean you know
so
because it does change the relationship
when you loan or borrow money it just
does so but the point being here is
there's not much of a relationship to
change so that's i'm doing it because
it's a cheaper interest rate saves money
make sure you have an attorney close the
deal like you would any other
professional transaction get title
insurance get an inspection on the house
get an appraisal on the house all of
those kinds of things you would do if
you're doing a normal transaction
to where you know one's getting screwed
here no one's there's all very
business-like and button-up all the
documents are done they're properly
filed at the courthouse a title company
does the closing you do everything right
here if you do all that right you're
going to have lowered cost and lowered
interest rate and it's a good deal go
get it
there you go
matthew's with us in tulsa oklahoma hi
matthew how are you
great how are you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
um i've just got kind of a career
question um but i was going to give you
a rundown of myself and my wife's
financials first
i make we're both self-employed um no
debt other than our home
i make about 120 she makes about 60.
we owe 160 on our home it's worth about
3 305
and i actually sell real estate look
really looking forward to the reality
check
um
and i'm just curious should i take the
chance
because i have an opportunity to start
my own brokerage
but should i take that chance with a
baby on the way with
all the risks that we know come with
starting your own company
so you're a real estate broker now
making 120 000 a year
i'm an agent yes
i'm getting my license shortly yes okay
how long have you been selling real
estate
a little over a year
okay i'm 22 my wife's 22 also okay
i was doing the same thing you're doing
when i was your age
um
and i got my real estate license when i
was 18.
okay so
i know what you're facing one of the
things you're facing is it's tough to
have credibility with people to sell
them houses when you're only 22. right
yeah you've got an uphill battle there
and having your own brokerage would
probably help with that a little or it
might scare or it might scare them even
more
well see i feel like i don't have as
much of a problem with customers as i
would with people working under me
because i've been doing it 20 years and
thinking about how young you are right
from like a leadership perspective
someone respected right yeah
and just with a kid doing october it's
like do we take this chance when we're
sitting pretty good right now yeah and
we've got a real estate market that is
um twisting and turning in the wind
it's uh it's very unpredictable right
now uh i mean i i
i think the market's gonna slow down
i don't think house prices are gonna go
down we've already said that out loud
but i think it's going to slow down
so my yeah my only concern would be
matthew you got into the real estate
business
in the best time ever so like
what you made then
not saying you can't make that again by
any means but it was probably easier to
make what you made then then it's going
to be easier to make that same amount in
the next coming years because of the
slowing and softening of the market so
what's your wife say
she says do it because it's a it's a
pretty good option i mean it's a pretty
good opportunity with a business partner
who has a very good end
i'm sorry a business partner
that's
new information
yeah i would be opening it with a with a
partner
no don't do that
oh really no
you're already married
yeah
all right listen the only ship on sale
is a partnership
the number of business small business
partnerships that survive one decade is
very close to zero
almost none of them do we work with
entre leadership businesses tens of
thousands of them and have for decades
all across america and one of the
biggest problems they have is a stinking
partnership it's gone sideways
now the exception is medical
partnerships and law partnerships but
they're structured differently anyway
it's a whole different set of setup but
two guys opening a real estate company
two guys opening up a uh heat and air
company two women open up a nail salon
this is just a it's just a no
no
no
no no you don't you don't need a partner
uh okay so what i what i'm gonna tell
you is is scary for me to tell you
because i believe in getting after it
when you're young and you're an
ambitious and smart young guy and i hate
to tell you not to do something but
while you uh get
another 18 months is going to give you a
lot of information about life a lot of
perspective especially if it's your
first baby too there's just a lot of
changes let the baby get born let's get
past some of this rough patch in the
real estate let's see what's going on
you save up you open up with your money
doesn't cost that much to open up a
brokerage firm if you open it up when
you're 25 instead of your 22 you're
gonna be just fine
and um a little patience yeah i think
it's gonna be good for you
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster
they walk you through the total cost of
your loan so you can make the best
choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free homeownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money thank you for joining us
joanna is with us in montana hi joanna
welcome to the ramsay show
hi
nice to be here good to have you how can
we help
yeah so i want to build a home on my on
my land
but i'm wondering if going with a
construction loan
is a good idea especially since i have
no credit because we're debt-free
okay what's your income
yeah it's around 90k
and that's my husband i i i work at home
what's he
do uh software he's a full stack
developer okay great do you guys have
any money saved joanna
um so we have three months worth of
money saved we had a rough year last
year so it kind of depleted we had six
months
and then now we just brought it back up
to three after
uh
having a rough year what what's a rough
year what happened
uh he lost his job for a year
for a whole year
which was kind of really unexpected does
he do contract work
no
um
no
he he has a regular work as a salary
did you work from home
um he didn't at the time but now he does
okay
and where are you all living now you
living on the land or what
no we found a temporary place that so we
bought a mobile house gutted
because renting was hard to find rent
and renting was expensive
and so my husband fixed up the whole
thing while he wasn't
working
and so now we're that's the reason why
we're debt-free because now we're living
in a three-bedroom two-bath mobile house
and is that on your phone
nope we're renting the lot oh okay yeah
unfortunately we weren't able to move it
to our land okay where are you gonna
what are you gonna spend on the house
you're building
we were thinking around 300k
and we're thinking yeah at about
1500 square feet no that's not a huge
house
okay
but yeah with materials everyone's
telling us that you know it'll be more
expensive
okay in order to get a construction loan
you would need a blueprint
that has been appraised
by an appraiser
uh the bank that you're getting the
construction loan mortgage company
you're getting construction loan can
help you with that
um and you will have to have a
contractor building the property
building the house
okay they don't loan money to people who
just think they might want to build a
house
and have never done it before okay so a
licensed contractor a blueprint an
appraisal
very detailed
financial package
um and then your you would qualify at
your local credit union or bank for a
construction loan even if you don't have
a credit score if you've got a steady
job you've got this piece of property
that's paid for what's the property
worth
um more than 100k yeah okay so you got
the effectively a 25 down payment
in other words you'd have a 400 000 deal
if you put a 300 000 house on a 100 000
piece of ground right
yeah and that'd be a 25 equity position
from day one so they'll take a lien
against your farm
and then they will dole out the money to
the contractor on a schedule
construction draw schedule
based on completion points as the house
goes up when the house is completed
you would get a
permanent regular mortgage that pays off
the
construction loan that's called the take
out loan and you will need to rearrange
your again the mortgage company of the
bank that'll help you with this will
probably help you will get your
permanent loan as well
because you have to have what's called a
take out letter how are you going to
take out
this construction loan
and you're going to take it out with a
new permanent regular mortgage
all of that lines up as dominoes and you
can build now
how long is it going to take you to save
300 000 if you don't
quite a few years
yeah
i mean if you say 50 a year out of 90
it's gonna take you six years
yeah it's true
so
that's that's the numbers that are
running through my head now if you take
that out and you get out a permanent
construction loan and then you viciously
attack that permanent mortgage after you
move in and you pay it off in five or
six years that'd be wonderful wouldn't
it
yeah it was as long as he's making 90 or
more and i if he's in tech world he
should be able to continue to do that
yeah
rachel went through building a house it
wasn't using a construction line a while
back but it is a detailed process it's
not something you just walk into and go
oh i want to put a house over there
yeah no there's there's a work yeah
you'll have a part-time job
johanna in that process but it's fun but
it's great yeah and it's and i think
it's exciting for you guys and with the
numbers and everything you guys have
worked hard to
be debt free and to be in the position
you are and so yeah making the step
forward i think is i think is great
okay so do you does that mean you guys
think it's a good time to build right
now
not now but you're not ready
you don't have a blueprint you don't
have a contractor you don't have an
appraisal you don't have any of this
lined up
i mean you're gonna you're gonna break
ground in next spring
maybe in the fall but i would probably
wait till spring
and let some of these lumber prices and
other things continue to calm down
lumber's back down but some of the other
stuff's not labor there's a serious
shortage on still in most areas
okay yeah i mean but you got a lot of
work to do to get ready to break ground
in the spring
yeah
well how do you know what order to do
all these things like i i did call a
contractor
then
get in touch with churchill mortgage and
see if they can do a loan there in
montana if they can't find your local
credit union talk to them about a
construction loan and a permanent
mortgage they'll help you get the
appraisal contractor can help you get
the blueprint
but you're gonna have to have all of
that you can't just say i think 1500 and
i think that's three thousand i heard
that's what i heard it costs that's that
doesn't work for getting a loan they're
not gonna they're loaning that person
money that does that
you gotta have like airtight business
case for this whole process whether
you've got a credit score or not
you've got to do all of that and the
land helps her
in that case because she owns it for a
lot of people and 100 debt free help
sure yes yeah yeah absolutely but a lot
of people that want to build don't have
lands right to build you have to roll
the land into the deal yeah and then
that becomes harder now you're talking
about a down payment issue right when
you do all that and that rolls in as
well
so um that is a question i've been
getting
quite a f well at least on social media
okay on instagram is yeah for the new
new construction home buying is it a
smart
time
to build a house that's
there's a lot of people asking that um
i'm probably going to build one next
spring
but i'm not you are yeah but not today
yeah
i was going to ask you where i want to
ask you on the air
well i haven't figured that part out yet
i didn't know but uh well i mean i you
know we moved we moved out of the big
house yeah and we're living in a a nice
home but we had planned a bill when we
yeah i knew that
no middle of this craziness we're not
gonna and it really i thought you all
were gonna take like three years just to
like do nothing i'll just
announce it to you right here on the air
so there you go but the uh um anyway
that's exciting
and good good for you
the point is lumber has stabilized i
think labor will smooth out by spring
it's still there's still a labor
shortage in general on construction so
construction is a little bit wacky wonky
still and i think it's going to be for a
little while longer
but i think most of the supply chain
crap will be behind us and that stuff
and i think we'll have a more normalized
environment and i kind of think the
economy is going to be a little slower
and so builders are not going to be
quite so snooty
uh about like they're doing you a
freaking favor or something you know
which is the way they act right now or
particularly acted six months if they
can yes
because they can like six months ago
they're doing you a favor or something
and i don't need them doing me a favor
and i'm building it oh we know that dave
we know that
oh my goodness
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
jake's in canada hi jake how are you
[Music]
hey dave uh pleasure to talk to you i
never thought i'd be able to actually
communicate with you but it's a blessing
well we're honored how can we help you
um so a little bit of a back story um i
got married at a pretty young age
so
you know life is good you know we're
doing the five baby steps we managed to
pay off a lot of debt and then
got a three to six months of an
emergency fund sitting
and um so a year and a half ago we were
blessed as a little baby boy
and
so now um you know our marriage started
getting really uh rocky it was like a
heart we had a hard time
and so um
now my wife uh she's
saying how like she doesn't want to be
together anymore she doesn't love me
anymore
she's talking to somebody else um like
in the middle of the night i'll hear her
on the phone with another person
and i just don't know what to do with
that and she wants to basically like
live at home still like in the same
house and so that she could raise our
son
but it's like it's a very like it's a
very difficult place for me to be in so
i just need some advice on that
i'm sorry
how old are you
uh 24.
okay
dude you don't deserve this
no it's uh i mean it's
i mean it takes two to break a
relationship right i'm not blaming her
on at all
100 but it's
like i i wanted to make things work we
were watching a marriage counselor and
everything
and for a while i thought things were
going good and then
about three weeks ago she said she was
done like she was completely done and
then like a couple days later she was
talking to somebody else already so it's
a
tough situation
and how old's the baby
uh he's a year and a half year and a
half oh jake i'm so sorry
yeah i mean what do you do
well
yeah i mean
in this case i mean if she's like
i mean in a sense having an emotional
affair and she's
you know talking to people and all that
i'm like she's breaking her vows
um
that she made with you
and
choosing not to
walk down a path that you guys can have
healing and move past this and so
so sure no one's perfect in a marriage
um but she's making these decisions
consciously to to go against everything
that you guys had in your marriage and
so
yeah i mean what they've said earlier
but i'm like
at that point like she doesn't she
doesn't get a lot of votes right now in
your life in my opinion
yeah
so yeah like okay
so let me let me back up and just
address your initial question okay
um
if you guys can work this out and be
married
and with a marriage counselor walk
through this this patch
and she can set the phone down and
devote her life to you you can set
your issues down and devote your life to
her
that's great and i hope that's what can
happen
if the if she actually gets wants a
divorce you can't stop her it's her you
can't make other people do things
okay i can't make my wife do anything
believe me
we've been married 40 years i can't make
her do anything
exactly and she really can't make me do
anything either in all fairness okay we
all make decisions as individual adults
okay
so you can't you can't make people do
what you want to do but what you can
decide is what's right for you
based on the decisions they're making
and um and you know when you say out
loud
we're going to get a divorce and live in
the same house
and be roommates that that's just
strange weird and dumb you know when you
say that out loud that it is all of
those things right
yeah yeah exactly like it's like
it's heartbreaking not even not even a
possibility okay if we're going to go
through a divorce that means we're not
going to be married and we're going to
have separate lives
no we're not living in the same house
that's asinine
right so she doesn't want to leave jake
is that this said she wants to stay in
the house she wants to be in the house
with you or she just wants the house
no she wants to because she doesn't have
a degree in anything
and for her to right now like the way
the market is right now for even renting
a home would be super hard for her so
she basically wants to just live there
and like so like she does not want to go
back to work so that's because she wants
to raise our son
which like if it would be better for him
i agree no it wouldn't no no it wouldn't
he does not need to be raised by
divorced parents living in the same
house together that's so freaking weird
is psychologically damaging to your son
no
yeah
no that's not better for your son
i it sounds this poor girl she's so
screwed up
i don't want to work
[Laughter]
and earn money but i don't want to be
married
well darling you can't you get to choose
one of the other
that's not the way this is going to work
out
so
yeah i i think if we're going to get a
divorce that she's going to have to go
get an apartment you guys are going to
sell the house and you're going to go
get an apartment
okay no you're not gonna live together
all right
i mean yeah
does that mean i mean you knew that
right
yeah i did and i just i just like i
didn't want to be the guy to just like
decide something you know and or to not
work out in the end so that's why i
think well if
if you guys staying in the same house
involves healing your marriage i'm all
for it
yeah but not work out in the there is
nothing where you divorce and live in
the same house together
that works out in the end
you're a highly unattractive single guy
at this point
that you live in a house with your ex
because it says it has a big arrow above
your head that says stupid
okay
no really that would not you don't want
to do this you don't want to do this no
i know you don't know
but oh no no no no
and and he seems like such a kind
person
so to have the conversation with her
jake is that she's doing this like
that's my thing you're not the one
putting her out on the street and not
letting her be home with her child she's
making decisions about her life that is
now choosing to isolate herself
because she's chosen to go against her
vows to her husband so like
yeah and yeah and you're probably not
perfect i'm not saying that but like
man
it is
you reap what you sow and there's a
level of consequences that she has to
face because she's making big girl
decisions and now she's about to get
some big girl results and she's got to
deal with that like that that's it's
unfair to you to be the brunt of all of
it and she calls me mean
that was very kind
i was very kind
but man it's just unfair to you jake
like i feel for you where i'm like
because you're a person even the way
you're asking the question you're so
nice no i'm not sure we're pretty sure
we're pretty sure you're not perfect but
you are a nice guy and you don't deserve
this so no we're gonna set up a normal
process that says you have a future
away from her if she doesn't want to be
with you she is a future away from you
because she doesn't want to be with you
we can't and then you can move on with
your life and she can move on with her
life and we've got this connection with
this one and a half year old and this is
all the caveat that for some reason if
there's an issue
that she's running from the marriage to
all these other relationships that you
guys in counseling and therapy can work
through and build a stronger marriage
that's our number one right number one
is that you guys can heal this over time
um but divorced and living in the same
house is not on the agenda yes okay it's
not on the sense not on the agenda we're
just taking that off the table just not
let's just be real clear if we hadn't
already been
the way you can look at some of these
things sometimes when you're in a fog on
the decision making folks whether it's
something deeply relational like that
where your brain just shuts down because
the stress levels so high
and you really can't see clear the way
you can the way you can get clarity when
you're overwhelmed with that kind of
stuff is just projected out ten years
okay ten years after moving in with your
ex
and living in the same house how's that
working out for you
and he probably knows that but following
through
with that decision means
confrontation with her
making her move or he's moving and like
you know what i'm saying like following
through with the repercussions of that
decision is messy and so entering into
that probably sounds exhausting for you
jake not his decision those hers
i mean
yeah yes yes that's what we're fighting
but his decision about living in the
house with her was search of horse which
is the right decision instantaneous yeah
doesn't take 30 seconds to make that one
not three seconds to make that one
sorry you're going through this young
man i hope it works out doesn't sound
like it's going to
that puts us hour the ramsey show in the
box
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today the phone number here is triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five david and carolyn in tacoma
washington are on the line it says on my
screen you guys are debt-free way to go
oh yeah dave it's it's been a great
journey it all started in
2015. we did our debt-free scream in
2017 for consumer debt and now we're
paying off our
love
house
how much have you paid off totally
um well the first time it was 82 000 the
consumer debt and then our house was 172
000. okay i'm going with 172 figure how
long did it take to do that
uh that took us four and a half years ah
you go and your range of income during
that time
um we started
about 117
and we finished this last year at 205
000. excellent what do you guys do for a
living
uh i do land development shout out to my
company uh hosford construction they
really help me pay off that last big
lump there you go and
and i just retired from the state i'm a
compliance unit manager for the state of
washington but i'm just retired in the
month of july so it's a perfect timing
dave yeah way to go that's an exciting
month david
pay off the house retiring all of it
that's great that's very cool
it was because we paid it off in may and
i retired at the end of june so the
timing was perfect and makes it a little
bit easier to retire amen well tacoma's
a great market what's that house worth
um about we figure about 50 450 000
phenomenal how much you guys got in
retirement savings
um
probably
with my my pension probably around five
hundred thousand but carolyn's eight
years younger than me she's still
working so
that's my retirement plan for a while
thanks
oh whoa
i'm married up dave oh i'm not sure
you're going to be there
[Laughter]
that's great man so you're millionaires
you did it your baby steps millionaires
we're getting there yeah you're right at
it way to go guys congratulations well
tell us the story what started this
journey and how did you get tied into
this ramsay stuff
well in in 2015 we we took it our took
um
fpu at your at the church
and um
so that took us 28 months to pay
82 000 off
and uh and then in 2017 after we paid
that off
we decided that we wanted to pay off our
house and
we slowly did it and
of course this last year we
our income increased a lot and that
really helped us a lot
and
and really
the biggest thing for us is
our kids are listening um
we we tithe through the whole thing
dave um we put god first and uh he
rewarded us yeah wow
very cool very cool what church are you
in
uh grace point northwest in enumclaw
washington yeah wonderful
very cool well way to go congratulations
you guys so how did it feel you know
this past july where you didn't have a
mortgage payment
oh it's just crazy you know it just
gives you rachel just gives you so much
freedom i
i think it's really to me it's really
that debt is a distraction
you know it's
the devil does all kinds of things to
mess with your family and your goals and
what god's plans are for your life and
that debt was really a distraction to us
and i know it is to a lot of marriages
and families and we just really feel
like now we're ready to take on that
next step which is what what is god plan
for us next and all of the choices and
the freedom that we have to do that is
just such a blessing
incredible oh incredible you guys that's
i just think that's such an amazing not
only accomplishment but even the
seasonal life that you guys are entering
with david you're retiring all of it i'm
like there is there's just freedom and
margin and options that you guys have
that that's coming up so
i'm i'm impressed very impressed and
congratulations
very proud of you guys very very well
done great great job we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you my
latest number one bestseller how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too you're there and
so you can read about essentially who
you are because that's you and uh we got
a copy of total money makeover for you
to give away and maybe get someone
else's journey and a one-year membership
to financial peace university the brand
new videos are out the best class we've
ever done and uh you can send someone
through it because it's what got your
journey started and so give you plenty
of things to give away a couple things
to read for yourself so beautiful well
done you guys well done well done who
are your biggest cheerleaders
oh probably
our our our kids
um
they
watched from afar but they were there
and uh we would give them little
tune-ups every once in a while to tell
them what where we were
and of course our church
um we had people in our church that
because we um
did financial peace about seven classes
and we haven't done it since well thank
you yeah we need to get started again
way to go man good job
good stuff so are your kids following in
the stuff
i i would say they're doing ramsay-ish
dave they
they hear what we're saying and you know
they're doing things now like saying mom
mom we paid cash for that
[Laughter]
good job good job they feel the need to
explain that's good i like that
good well way to go you two all right
it's david and carolyn tacoma washington
172 000 paid off in the second stage as
they paid off their house in four and a
half years making 117 to 205 took them
28 out 28 months to pay off the first 82
000 of consumer debt so that's a fairly
normal little bit shorter than normal
timeline that they've been on very very
very well done david and carolyn count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
one
two three we're dead free
[Applause]
that's how it's done boys and girls
man i love it
i love it they are set up that was an
interesting
comment i haven't heard uh many times
before that that is a distraction
distraction
keeps your eyes all the other places
it keeps your eyes off the things that
should be on instead you're having to
deal with this crap
you know it's a distraction i mean
illness is a distraction right there's
lots of things that distract us from
things that are
that that are the long-term play that
are the vision
those kinds of things allow you just be
in the presence too yeah yeah you can't
can't just can't be where you're
supposed to be yeah yeah that's good
very very very insightful carolyn very
good good stuff
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today open phones at
825-5225
[Music]
well when it comes to real estate
everyone has questions theories and
there's a lot of feelings out there
about real estate rachel and george and
i have spent the morning going over the
material with our team getting ready to
do a huge live stream it looks like
there's going to be well over 100 000 of
you viewing it uh tomorrow night for
most of you listening it's it's going to
be the 14th of july thursday evening
7 00 p.m
central eight eastern
it is completely free to watch it'll be
about an hour long maybe a little bit
more a little bit less somewhere in
there but we're going to cover the
actual data
of what is going on in the housing
market not your feelings
we're going to address your feelings
because a lot of you have a lot of
feelings about this but the real estate
reality check live stream completely
free
completely free
we want you to join us and we're going
to help you
because there's a lot of anger and fear
and angst and everything else out there
about this and anytime we run into that
then we know folks are potentially
getting ready to make mistakes and we
want to keep you from having to do that
we don't want you calling in and going
oh you know back in backing off 22 i
made this huge mistake and you know i
don't want you to do that so we're going
to help you that's what we want to do go
to ramseysolutions.com reality check get
your free registration so you can watch
tomorrow
night free and you'll be able to we'll
be able to do that straight up for you
we'll send you a link and boom you'll be
on rachel i'm excited about this
material i think it's solid no i think
it's a great event too because
the way we structured it is giving
people what they need most which in this
point it's facts
you need to know exactly why the real
estate market is the way it is what's
happening today versus what happened in
2008
you want to look at supply and demand
and inventory and buyers and population
i mean there's just there's a lot out
there a lot of facts that determine the
real estate market and so learning that
and going through it is really important
so we wanted to do that side kind of
that education piece but then also
address what the average american's
thinking and feeling whether you're
wanting to buy or sell or nothing you're
just hearing the news and you're looking
at social media and everyone's opinion
of what's going to happen is the world
coming to an end and it can be scary if
you go if you go down a black hole of
some of these things which i may or may
not have in my lifetime
uh you do like start to think oh my gosh
but i'm also intrigued by some of the
things we've learned just in preparing
for this
yeah but you know one of the graphs we
were looking at this morning and we'll
show it tomorrow night again
um that four states
have had almost a million people leave
them
in the last
uh
just under a year and um they all went
to
about eight states or six states yeah
okay
and um that was very interesting to me
uh that that these political decisions
around coveton around taxes
and around violence
um and protests and those kinds of
things are driving migration
and so you're you're seeing the states
they're moving to
you've got like californians moving to
tennessee
in record numbers we live in tennessee
it's almost a joke now how many
california california we just read a
report that they've had
actually net was it negative growth for
the first time first time in history
okay yeah
keeping
yeah california went down in population
for the first time since we've been
keeping pretty well but that but and
that affects it right because if you're
here in nashville we were just kind of a
pretty normal city i feel like and all
of a sudden we got this huge influx of
extra buyers with all this money because
they sell their homes in california and
they come here and you're like holy crap
and they're overpaying whoa
you bought you you had that much money
you know nashvillians got greedy too it
was funny it's like oh we got a
california sucker fish let's just suck
you know let's get that and they you
know add an extra 300 000 bucks to the
house price and boom and they'd pay it
and that happened in florida texas i
mean yeah we have all the data to show
up but it's just it is it's wild how
though yes there's so much that affects
the real estate market and including
that kind of stuff like you watch it's
just interesting yeah geographically how
things are shifting and depending on the
state you live in the market you live in
another one that was intriguing that i
kind of suspected
but i was a little bit shocked was the
investor dollars no huge number of
institutional investors buying houses
and so it's like 28 of the houses sold
last year which is crazy
it's kind of sad but um the uh but but
they're they they have
uh
this is not investors like oh i'm gonna
go buy a piece of real estate not a
single it's not like a single person in
your neighborhood that just wants to go
buy a house that's not these are
institutional big blocks of money coming
in and swooping up houses left and right
so it's kind of not good in that regard
but what's interesting is the cities
that have had the violence
and the uh the the lawlessness running
amok the investors are abandoning them
you know they're having like two percent
of the houses selling in seattle or in
portland or in uh uh minneapolis
uh
are investors
okay versus like nashville is uh 30
okay and so that's charlotte north
carolina charlotte north carolina huge
jacksonville florida huge i know but
that's where my but but all the
investors i don't know it's not it's a
mixed bag okay but it's it is
interesting that the investors are
staying away from cities
where uh where there's a
an over abundance of coveted rules
and or
violence
in the streets they're staying away from
them and so they're ruining the economy
in a sense now again i'm not i'm not a
huge fan of investors coming and
swooping up institutional investors
buying blocks of houses and taking them
off the market i'm not a fan of that
that's not the point but it is an
indicator of what happens when the point
is this politics
and uh social policy
and whatever you want to bucket just
this stuff in has economic consciousness
there's a lot of a lot of economic
consequences a lot of factors i don't
know what the other consequences would
be i don't know what the other factors
would be that's it i mean it's the only
distinguishing thing between portland
oregon well taxes socially there's
schools i mean you could there's a
there's a whole list of stuff i think
that go into it too
but anyways for the average person
though listening
and watching
the point of the event for us was to
give instruction education and actual
data of what's going on and to and to
just simmer down the fear and the panic
that this is going to be like 2008
because the data is showing it's it's
just not the way the supply and demand
work like there is still a low level of
supply with houses and still a high
demand to buyers and so so looking at
those data points is really really key
and really important and it inserts
again a level of like
take a deep breath it's gonna be okay
because when you start to fear and panic
and freak out and go down your
black hole of conspiracies which i may
or may not have done you're like oh my
gosh shouldn't i be what am i gonna be
okay i need to wait okay off the grid
i'm going to montana you're never going
to find me again montana's not a bad
place to go that's great i know i might
end up there i love it what i've read
comes true let me tell you what we were
just in big sky the economy there's
booming
man they got they're building stuff left
then right it's crazy hotels and houses
coming out of the ground like crazy it's
a wonderful market so but yeah
montana's good people i'm just saying i
know but i may be with them soon
i don't know why you picked montana
because it just feels
it feels like i could be off the grid
well yeah you could there's not as many
people there that's for sure or north
dakota north dakota yeah for sure not as
many people there south dakota that's
yeah okay if that's what you're after
you can find it there
yeah lots of prairie dogs no people
that's it so um anyway open phone's here
we're talking to you about your life and
your money but jump on
ramseysolutions.com and plan to uh watch
the live stream tomorrow night uh we're
giving you a little bit of a sneak peek
there with a couple things but um it's
always good for us as personalities our
content team our production team
everybody else to study some of these
things more in depth and you know test
our theories our hypothesis against the
actual data and is there actual data
there to support what we believe
if not do we need to shift why we're
doing that and so forth because you
caught well because in the past because
i'm just looking on social too on posts
you've done on instagram and stuff and
people like you're so wrong dave you're
so wrong it is going to crash
uh uh but you predicted inflation this
time last year but you said on another
show you did not predict the recession
and oh eights in fact i was very strong
that was not going to happen okay so
what so did you just not see
the real estate market like you know i'm
saying like what did you miss that
you're confirmed that you didn't you're
not missing here what happened there was
i did not anticipate nor did i believe
that the mortgage-backed securities and
the hedge funds had screwed up the
market with the subprimes as much as
they did yeah it was a lot bigger
problem than i realized at the time and
that's just simply not there now right
right it's not even a factor in this
discussion
so yeah i missed that one um but so much
of economics is self-fulfilling prophecy
if you believe it you act on it and you
cause it to become true
and you got to be careful with that with
predictions of negative things in the
economy this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today mark is with us in
nashville hey mark how are you
good how are you dave better than we
deserve man
thank you what's up
hey um so uh we've been listening me and
my wife have been listening your show
for the past six years and we're able to
pay off all our student loan debt and
follow the baby steps and we kind of got
off the beaten path a little bit
recently and we uh
we bought a piece of land we live in the
nashville area
and
we're kind of facing this decision uh
now
we want to be completely debt-free and
if we sell our house and uh
and uh rent we would like to build a
property on or build a house on this
piece of land in the next three to four
years
um we would be
we'd be able to pay off the rest of the
land and be completely
debt-free and
actually be able to save a little bit
more money per month
while renting
and
we were just kind of wondering if that
was a smart idea or
um i know there's just so much going on
with the real estate market in nashville
uh we're just not
sure what to do i have a really good
income
um
so we'll be able to save a lot of money
in the next few years
good what's your income
anywhere from
230 to 250. excellent very very good
okay what's your house payment
uh like 900 a month
no you don't sell your house you can't
rent cheaper than that
well we we have we have to pay money on
the land as well so yeah but you gotta
pay money on the land if you sell the
house and rent
right but we would be able to pay off
the balance of the land if we sold their
house
oh your deck the equity out of the house
should do that okay so what are you all
on the land yeah
uh we owe about 260 000. what do you owe
on your house
about 200
okay what could you sell the house for
about 500
okay
i would just sit right there dude i sit
right there and i would plow through
this land
it's hard i throw money at this land
hand over fist
and get it paid off and then start
talking about building a house on that
land
okay uh i guess we just um
i would just feel like you know in in
the next three to four years like
if we sold our house it it would
it would take a lot of risk out of
everything if you want to sell it sell
it okay you don't need me to do that
okay but but right but you got to live
somewhere and you have a 900 house
payment on a house that's going up in
value while you're pulling off all these
other tricks
and you're abandoning both of those good
things
to go ahead and get the land paid off
that's what i wouldn't do
okay but you can do whatever you want to
it's obvious you you know
you make a lot of money you're doing
great none of these things are in the
stupid column it's just a matter which
one's going to be the fastest
most expedient but i mean you priced
rent in nashville right
yeah we we in the area that we're
looking um
for the same size house would be about
2500 bucks a month yeah and i make about
20 000 a month
i know
what you make a month is a is the static
piece of information in either one of
these scenarios
but the the two things what we're
comparing against is nine hundred a
month that goes up in value or twenty
five hundred dollars a month in the
middle of the table on fire
yeah
y'all just want out of debt is your
motivation mark for asking the question
because you guys just wanna be pay
everything off and it just feels better
and then you're renting like is that
what you're is that what you guys are
feeling both of you
i guess it just feels more simple and
it just
because because um i know that that
like you say that the housing prices are
supposed to go up but there's a chance
also that they could go down and i just
feel like if you're going to sell you
want to sell now i think you're making a
mistake because you're you really do
think house prices are going to going to
go down and i think you're wrong
especially in nashville mark right
i think you're wrong yeah
i think you've been hanging out with the
wrong people at the bar
oh my gosh
and they're all talking they're all
talking i don't know no they're all talk
your friends are all talking trash i
want to hear mark what you have to say i
really do because i hear the same thing
so go
for our specific scenario um you know in
the next three four years that
how much are it's like how much our
house is really going to go up and is
that worth the risk of
keeping it for that long what's causing
you mark to think that what's causing
you mark to think that your house price
is going to go down here in nashville
why why do you think that
i don't know that it's going to go down
but i don't know that the amount that it
will go up but why why are you coming to
these conclusions
give me like data give me a reason
because
the price of our houses has more than
doubled in the past six years and i just
i don't see
that amount of increase at the
percentage of increase i i think i mean
it may increase but i i don't know if
that increase over three to four years
is going to be worth
the risk of us keeping
the house versus being out of debt the
risk
of the debt on the land
yeah
like say that on our our house in the
land like if
say if something happened to my job or
something in the next three to four
years
it would be
pretty
i don't know you could sell either one
or both of these properties
yeah yeah i guess i just worry about
if the demand will still if there's
still going to be the demand at the core
of all of this back and forth in your
verbal is you really don't you are
really worried that house prices are
going to go down you really do believe
there's a high probability they're going
to go down and that's at the core of
your question and that's why i think
you're wrong
okay now you can do what you want to do
there's no real downside except a little
bit of lost money on you selling your
house today
but so sell it today and go pay off your
land and go rent
but then go back and look when you
finish this transaction three years from
now and see what the house that you sold
did
and then we can determine if i was right
or not but um
and mark let me say this though because
the marketing the market is softening it
is making people be like oh wow so yes
houses are going back to what they
actually are valued at
and what appraisal is coming in
at yes versus in nashville we all knew
this like three months ago i mean six
nine months ago
someone here at the office they got 56
offers over a weekend like and it was
like 200 over asking for i mean just you
hear the craziest stories you heard the
craziest choices you're not gonna have
that anymore so i think that's gonna but
that doesn't mean that the value of your
home is gonna tank because no supply is
not gonna catch up with demands here in
the near future and i think that and i
honestly do think that there are still
these areas around the country we talked
about this last segment insurance has 25
000 employees in downtown nashville
amazon has 25 000 employees and the
health care industry
two companies
you can't beg a house in nashville right
now because these huge corporations have
moved in here and made it their
headquarters okay and they're moving out
of new york they're moving out of
california and they're moving in here
and setting up shop because we're a
tax-free income tax again if you were
houston mark if you were i mean another
place maybe we could have you know
another you're not in a market that's
going to crash dude now again if you
want to do this the only thing you've
lost is whatever you didn't make on your
house
and so it's not a huge like there's
nothing nothing here in the stupid
column but what i what i want to teach
you and people listening is when you
make decisions based on feelings instead
of real data
on negative feelings fear
it almost never leads to good financial
consequences
and so at the core of your
concern at the core of your question is
a false assumption that real estate in
nashville tennessee is going to go down
in the next two years it's not
it's not
if it does call me and i'll buy your
house
it's not
okay seriously but now if you want if
you just want the peace of mind go to
the bar that mark is hanging out with
and tell all the friends i was wrong
i'll buy y'all no i don't buy everybody
in the bar's house i'm not buying a
round i'm just buying his but it's just
not gonna happen it's just not gonna
happen okay so you know you're okay
you're okay
but if you want to sell it it's also
okay
you're not dumb for being 100 debt free
you're not dumb but i just don't want
you to make decisions based on fear
and
and feelings rather than data
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 4 25
26 let your eyes look straight ahead fix
your gaze directly before you
give careful thought to the paths for
your feet and be steadfast in all your
ways
ross perot said the most successful
people in the world aren't usually the
brightest they are the ones who
persevere so
[Laughter]
unbelievable you guys are so bad
i have all these charts and graphs for
the real estate event for tomorrow night
we were going through the rehearsal
stuff this morning i said this is just
like ross pro and she said you mean bob
ross no no no what was it you said i you
i said
uh
yeah i was like well all your graphs
you've got so many graphs for this event
and he was like i know i'm like ross pro
you probably don't even know who he is i
was like yes i watched him all the time
on pbs painting his hair and everyone
was like that's popper
poor bob ross he just got insulted being
called for all right so we got a ross
pro freaking quote from ross perot well
these guys in the booth they're
unbelievable the most successful people
in the world aren't usually the
brightest
i heard the story right before the show
i couldn't resist whatever whatever
jesus that is awesome
i thought charts art so rachel a little
history lesson i know
i know against bush and he would always
get up with these with his part he was
running as an independent and he
actually got caused bush to get beat
okay he took his votes and he would get
up there and this is the graph and he
would do this whole thing and it is this
horrible nasal voice and it was just it
was it was running for president and he
always had charts and graphs he was not
a painter i know i know
no you don't
you're a child
i know politics i do i know the history
in like the 80s and 90s of politics
oh my gosh
oh man ross perot the painter there we
go
hey by the way folks uh we are doing
that real estate reality check tomorrow
night it is a live stream it's free
we're doing four building wealth events
in the fall
in your cities
and that includes phoenix arizona which
i just got an email at the break sold
out
phoenix is sold out
so those of you didn't get your tickets
for phoenix we'll catch you next time
um and you know be ready be watching be
listening so
sold out sold out and uh completely sold
out
maybe we'll talk them into opening up
another night or something but it's gone
and uh sacramento is almost sold out um
can't think of the other cities off the
top of my head but they're they're
they're all right on the verge of
selling out for the fall here you need
to go and get those tickets those are
not free the event tomorrow night you go
to ramseysolutions.com and register for
the real estate reality check is
completely free of this live stream
okay marco is with us in la hey marco
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how you doing man what an honor
seriously how are you guys better than
we deserve sir how can we help you
all right so dave my question today for
you is so i'm 21 years old i am on
i'm going back to school in the fall and
uh i've got two years
down under my belt i was a little
i was out of school for a little over a
year
just trying to decide what i wanted to
do did some internships live in florida
for a little bit i came back
so basically going back to school to
finish my undergrad in business uh
decided i want to do that kind of build
a little bit of a career out of it and
also but my end goal is to go back to uh
get my master's in theology so being a
pastor plant a church would be uh
definitely you know what god will truly
i believe god has called me to do
um but here is my question so i'm a
first gen so going back to college is a
huge huge deal
my parents supportive in everything that
i've done um
but here's the thing uh like i said my
parents are or i'm a first gen to my
parents that makes my parents uh south
american immigrants and so the financial
decisions that they've made when they
first came here weren't always the best
um i've you know i've i grew up and you
know we've had to suffer we've had to
sacrifice a lot but uh we're not where
we used to be and we're i know we're
headed to a better place uh with that
being said uh that's kind of wired me to
think 10 years ahead so i'm enrolled at
a school uh biola university here in la
and i've gotten the final numbers of how
much it's going to cost me how much um
it's money that i how much it's 13 600
for one semester
that's a little high
it is it's very high and that's that's
one semester so that's just fall of 2022
and so i'm not even sure what spring of
2022 is going to look like yeah i'm not
mad i'm not mad at viola but you need to
go somewhere you can afford
you don't have any money yeah
absolutely i just i don't wrong school
i'm not sure if it's worth
it's not sure if it's worth taking out
no the amount you know i'll be
after two years of college i'll be maybe
in 40 50 k
in debt and that's maybe like a base pay
of
a business degree you know coming fresh
out of college that's maybe like the
base pay of a salary
so i'm not sure if it's worth being the
same amount of debt but the same amount
of income i'll be making in a year no
it's not
not when you could have gotten the
degree cheaper and worked your way
through and had no debt
right you just chose the wrong school
you chose a school you can't afford it i
haven't i mean i haven't taken out any
loans yet i haven't made any payments
good um so change schools so
okay
if viola won't give you if biola won't
give you scholarships and they probably
won't they may not if you qualify for
scholarships based on the immigrant
status of your parents or something like
that that'd be awesome
but um dude california has free
community college
right yeah i mean i'm currently doing
some classes online through uh
for the summer right now just to kind of
get back into the rhythm of doing uh
school again but uh
yeah if i were in your shoes i would
work 50 to 60 hours a week and i would
go to a school i could afford and pay
cash for
right i did that by the way and get all
your prereqs done marco if you can at at
a community college that's free in
california and then seeing okay what
trans what credits transfer and maybe
you just spend two semesters at a
different university versus two years
if you want a diploma from a different
university then you can do that if the
credits transfer go see the cottons
counselor at viola and tell them you're
getting ready to withdraw if you can't
figure out some scholarships and we've
got the immigrant status of your parents
on your side we've got the fact that
you're an adult student coming back on
your side there's a lot of different
programs out there for all kinds of
people and see if they won't help belly
up and help you here if they cut that in
half you can afford to pay cash for it
if your ultimate goal too is
to get a degree um in business and theo
well eventually theology
what's causing you not just to go down
yeah
is that just like a far off dream in the
in the way future or is that something
that you could just pursue now and skip
the business degree if
that's what you want
uh well
you know i
i've thought a lot about it i've talked
to pastors of mine i've talked to you
know financial advisors that are also
friends of mine and everything and you
know i'd love to be able to build an
income outside of the church um to be
able to have something uh
more so kind of like a either whether
that be a passive income or something i
can do so i don't have to take a salary
from the church that would be a goal of
course not always like that but
um okay just to do things a little bit
differently yeah i hear that very cool
what i want you to do is i want you to
look at a lot of hard work
look at some scholarships
um and and look at affordability of
where you're going to school and go get
your degree in a way that you can pay
cash for it
between those between those three things
and even if that means pausing another
semester that's what i would do if i
were in your shoes and even if it means
because there's no magic to viola okay i
mean i'm not mad at them i'll hire you
if you graduated from there if you if
you meet the other things on our uh
hiring process but where you went to
school we have 1200 employees 1200 team
members we have never in the history of
this company we've hired 2 000 something
over the years
okay never in the history of this
company we hired someone because of
where they went to school
and you and a lot of small business
owners across america where people are
working like almost all exactly so
couldn't give up
school they cares did you learn
something while you were there
and so don't tell me where you went to
school and act like that qualifies you
to be something that's just that's just
prestige throwing it around and prestige
will buy you nothing
in this world and very in very small
industry in industries and very small
sectors of different parts well if you
can find that one percent of people that
are so snobby that they won't hire you
unless you went to a certain school
that's fine but it's one and a half
that's what i'm saying like it's
majority of people out there don't care
where you went yeah i care can you
hustle and grind i hear did you learn
something can you pull those tools out
of your belt and kill something and drag
it home that's what i want to know is as
an employer that's what i'm looking for
and so cool stuff you're a good man
marco this is good luck to you and
congrats on everything you're doing
incredible job incredible that puts us
out with the ramsey show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
you